congrats on this and i've been wanting
to ask you this all day when first
presented with the idea were you like oh
yeah it's time to pass the hulk baton or
were you kind of like no the hulk's my
thing
no i was uh i was i was into it i
thought it was going to be fun yeah yeah
i mean um there's room for more of
course
i'm the third one doing it
um you posted a birthday tribute to
chris i also wanted to mention this
do you miss the guy are you like excited
to get back on set at some point
together what can you tell us yes i was
disappointed that i wasn't in love and
thunder but uh
but i still love them yeah and we're
gonna make more thunder that's right
that's right we have to keep making
thunder
there's a few easter eggs in this thing
that kind of let us down to believe the
the world war hulk storyline
are you up for a solo hulk movie
anytime they want to do it i'm i'm here
all right
all right last but not least i'll let
you get out of here um kevin has
obviously revealed that all this is
going to kind of event and
end in avengers secret war
um how do you think this will compare to
endgame what do you what do you think
what can you tell us what can you tease
us with well it's gonna be hard to top
end game but um
if i know kevin and i know marvel it's
gonna be pretty amazing it'll be a big
bang yeah we'll go out with a big bang
you